across Health and Care across government
across Society on the whole idea of
prevention we had over 600 submissions
and the team are analyzing them now and
very shortly we will publish them and
our plans for our areas of focus as this
inquiry progresses throughout this part
of this year what I can tell you is that
they're very broad so from some more
obvious stuff from obesity and smoking
to mental health and from clean air
which we'll definitely come on to today
to healthy homes healthy workplaces and
there'll be different work streams
within that I guess today we couldn't
really start with a more top level than
our main guest who who is Professor sir
Chris Whitty he's the chief medical
officer who is very well known
um in any way but certainly very well
known because of his high profile role
during the covid pandemic and thank you
for all your work on that Chris we also
are joined by Jonathan marrow who's
heading up the office for health
Improvement and disparities the
Department of Health social care and Dr
Chanel de Gucci who's the deputy chief
medical officer for England thanks very
much for joining us and giving evidence
to us today to kick of this important
inquiry
Professor with you if I could start with
you the NHS is is never out of the
headlines as as you know
um the strikes
obviously another strike announced
yesterday by potentially by Junior
doctors about money but as much we're
here anyway about the system and the
shared Demand on it which of course hits
staff very hard we heard from GMB unions
for Christmas about 10 times the number
of calls coming into the ambulance
service with the Secretary of State told
us about 100 times the number of people
in hospital with flu this winter we know
the NHS in England spends more than 10
billion pounds a year dealing with
Diabetes Care and there are so many more
examples obviously
can I ask you as to start this session
to start this inquiry in your view as
our chief medical officer is the NHS
sustainable in the future without a
complete step change in how we prevent
ill health
thank you chairman because this is the
first session of what I I know is going
to be quite an involved thing do you
mind if I give a relatively long answer
to that just to start it to frame it I
was hoping my other questions will be my
other answers will be a lot shorter but
I just thought it might be that is quite
helpful
um
pretty clearly uh the only way that you
can you know there are essentially there
are three things you can do to make the
NHS uh more more efficient and effective
and therefore for all of us as Citizens
and for those of us who work in it uh
make this able to work for the medium
and long term
uh the first of them uh which this
inquiry is looking at is prevent disease
a very large amount of the most severe
disease is either preventable completely
can be pushed out in time so that people
have at a much later stage of their
lives or can be caught early at which
point it's a lot easier much more
pleasant or at least less unpleasant to
treat and indeed cheaper to treat than
if it's dealt with that if this is all
the work of prevention there are clearly
then things we can do in terms of the
NHS itself how it's run which I think is
for obviously for other points in your
inquiries and then finally and
importantly there's the issue of people
who need social care following the NHS
which again is a very major part of this
all three of those are important but I'm
gonna you know this this session is
about the first of those prevention yes
prevention has an absolutely massive
role in some diseases has a significant
role in some and has almost no role in
others and it's important to lay those
out I think and that's what I'd realize
I'd like to do in my first few comments
and then we can take any of them in
detail
um let's start off with an example of a
disease which is almost entirely
preventable not completely at 79
preventable uh I'll take two two cancers
um and there's different sorts of
prevention the first cancer I'll take is
cervical cancer and young largely in
young women
this is something which we now can
prevent almost all deaths if we look 10
10 to 30 years to the Future mainly by
vaccination because this is something
which is driven by infection
and also by screening because screening
allows us to pick it up at such an early
stage it can be treated incredibly
quickly as a day case really minimal uh
trauma for the women involved relative
to if it goes on later and the cancer
research UK would say this is
essentially now 99 preventable once we
look out to the Future once the cohort
of girls who are vaccinated turning to
women and into the period at risk and in
another cancer which is highly
preventable is lung cancer lung cancer
is our number one killer of a cancer
it's a horrible way to die most people
are diagnosed die within a year very
unpleasantly 79 of all lung cancers are
preventable the great majority of that
is caused by smoking and then there are
also some additional issues in terms of
industrial processes and some issues in
terms of air pollution as well but the
big one really is smoking if smoking
disappeared the great majority of this
the worst of our cancers would just
disappear at The Other Extreme the most
common cancer in men prostate cancer
there is nothing that we currently know
that can be done actually to prevent it
there isn't an effective screening
mechanism there is no preventative
systems this is really all about early
diagnosis and treatment so I'm just
making the point that there is a variety
depending which disease you're talking
about but actually the majority of the
largest diseases we worry about the
cardiovascular disease is heart heart
attacks and cardiovascular disease
Strokes most of the cancers for example
breast cancer bowel cancer we can either
prevent them substantially or at least
to a large enough degree to make a very
big difference to people's lives and to
the NHS so there's a lot we can do just
to take a uh two examples of mha and
then I'll obviously leave it if you can
bring in the point I'm making about
sustainability yeah so given demand
exactly so I'm going to take the the
example I'm going to use is coronary
heart disease
uh when I was training in medicine uh
coronary heart disease dominated the
medical take to a very large degree 50
of people uh back uh in the 60s I'm not
that old but uh back in the 60s would
have died of coronary heart disease in
the UK that rate has gone down to 25 of
people will die of uh heart to heart
disease or cardiovascular disease now
that's a vast Improvement but actually
also people are not getting the unstable
angina the major events that have put
them into the NHS in the first place now
what has led to that Improvement it's
broadly three sets of things there's
primary prevention that's things which
are done to everybody we all as Society
do them they have to be directed by
political leaders who are elected it's a
societal Choice that's things like
reducing smoking reducing salt uh allow
improving areas of people to exercise a
variety of things which will be done to
everybody and that improves the
cardiovascular health of the whole
population
um then you have secondary prevention
and that's things which is done based on
someone's individual risk and these this
is true for all the diseases but I'm
taking heart disease as the example
and those are things like identifying
that someone has hypertension putting
them on antihypertensive they've got
high cholesterol they're on a
cholesterol lowering drug or indeed
they're individually smoking and helping
them individually to come off because we
fail to prevent smoking in the first
place and then finally this treatment
and that's the bit which is since that's
beyond this inquiry but the primary
prevention probably was the principal
reason for the big reductions we saw in
cardiovascular disease from the 60s
through to around about the 80s and
increasingly then secondary prevention
became important and if you look at
people dying of heart diseases per
hundred thousand over time for men
that's dropped from 1280 ish to about
300 now that's a very substantial
Improvement and in women it's dropped
from about 889 down to 210 over that
time period and that's made up of a
combination of lots of steps on primary
prevention lots of steps on second
prevention and improve treatment is when
you put those together that you then get
significantly better health and much
less pressure on the NHS so you have to
kind of think there are lots of things
we do primary lots of things we do on
secondary and lots of things we do on
treatment medicine is made up of lots of
incremental steps but a very large
proportion of them for most diseases are
on the preventative side and then the
final thing just to highlight is that
within the UK
the prevention that we have is very
badly distributed around the population
so if you look at our most deprived
areas the period of time people live in
ill health and indeed how long they live
is very significantly lower than our
most affluent areas that's clearly not
biologically necessary
so to take a a well-known example uh in
in Blackpool for example people live
eight years shorter on average varies
hugely around around the city it's a lot
of hierarchy but also more importantly
in many ways they live 19 years
fewer years in good health so they also
therefore are living their lives in a
very constrained way and this is due to
preventable things and I'll just take
two examples of that and then I'll sort
of see where the committee wants to go
one of them is smoking smoking which
drives a large proportion of the
cardiovascular disease The Strokes and
heart attacks a large proportion of the
cancers not just lung cancer but
esophageal cancer bladder cancer many
other cancers that is twice as high
usually in people in lower incomes twice
more than twice as high in people living
with mental health issues the cigarette
industry goes absolutely unearthingly
for the most vulnerable in society and
you have a situation where the a great
majority of people who smoke will have
taken up smoking before they are 18 and
the group almost all of them will have
taken up smoking before their 20. I.E
the cigarette industry goes to the most
vulnerable teenagers
and it aims to addict them at that stage
of their lives
and then when they find they can't come
off
uh they're they're hooked most people
who smoke don't want to smoke this is
framed by the cigarette industry as an
issue of choice actually they have
deliberately taken the most vulnerable
children and to people in society and
taking their choice away from them by
addicting them at an early stage of
their life
so that's one of the reasons the
difference is deprivation uh the second
the second one uh issues of obesity so
if you look at obesity uh in reception
year uh if you look at the highest and
the lowest socioeconomic groups at
reception it would be 13 living people
living in obesity would be third a bit
over 13 in the most deprived areas and
about six percent in the least deprived
areas by the time we get up to uh year
six and remember these are still young
children it's 30 uh in uh the uh the um
the most deprived areas and about uh
between 13 and 14 in the least private
dose that's just two big drivers of ill
health so it's very heavily skewed
towards areas of deprivation I'll stop
there chair and take it in any direction
do you worry about the NHS and it's it's
viability given the trajectory that
we're on because all the things you said
about obesity all the things you said
about smoking they're not being turned
around they're continuing so do you
worry
as CMO about the viability of the NHS if
it continues to have this level of
demand into it might since my job is to
try and see if we can improve it and I
think what is really clear is we can on
this on smoking we can definitely
improve things we can prove things on
air pollution we might want to come back
to that we can improve things on
exercise there's lots of things we can
do to do that a Beastie is the one that
is going in the wrong direction on this
one it's a very major cause of multiple
diseases so that's a very significant
one to aim for but there are certainly
things we can do to turn that tie that
has been going up are down over time so
my view is these preventable things can
all be
turned around if there is the will to do
so okay I guess we're trying to get at
is is there so in the British medical
journal this month you you called for
secondary branch of services to be
restored and extended postcovid if I if
I look at your annual conference speech
to the local government Association last
a year ago next month you said that many
areas of Public Health at quotes either
trodden water or gone backwards since
the beginning of the pandemic and you
were referring specifically that I think
to smoking a Beastie alcoholism as
growing public health issues you called
for a long-term and local approach to
prevention so the Secretary of State
seems to agree with you that prevention
is Central to his mission I wonder
whether you think it is Central to his
mission and to this government's mission
but I think if you think about the
primary prevention the secondary
prevention I think it definitely should
be and the secretary of state has made
clear he says it is and the Prime
Minister has said it is uh
primary prevention issues are largely
ones of political Choice yes so that is
really in this building the the
decisions and in local Authority uh
elected leaders as well where decisions
around things like smoking are made so
that is a political Choice and then
there are issues of secondary prevention
which is what I was writing talking
about in the in the bmj that is mainly
around the distribution of resources in
the NHS in the broadest sense so they're
not just doctors and nurses but also
pharmacists physios others who work in
the system and certainly my view would
be and I think this is shared by most
people and this is the reason the NHS
have very much swung behind this is
putting more resource into that
secondary prevention with NHS would be a
good investment for the future because
it would help to slow down the speed of
the hamster wheel which otherwise goes
ever faster and we'd really need to put
a lot of emphasis on that area of
medical care and nursing care widest
Healthcare as well as in a sense that
making the case politically for instance
for ministers clearly to do that there
are choices to be made on primary
prevention and if Parliament chooses to
enact some of the things it could do we
could improve things like air pollution
reduce things like smoking and reduce
the risks of obesity and the most
vulnerable so those are political
choices but it's but it's self-evident
that those choices are not being made to
the extent that you would like correct
okay my job is to make the case that
public health is important so
unsurprisingly I think these are very
important issues yes and then just
finally just in five minutes or so I'm
going to bring in James Morris who wants
to talk to you about mental health
um your annual report last year made air
pollution and its effect on health it's
Central pillar of of the report it was
good to see and I know you've been in
Parliament this morning talking to your
party group about exactly that
um
we have a major issue with air pollution
in this country and his driver of
cardiovascular disease and you made the
link with cancer
I just wonder if you would give us some
of your thoughts on air pollution and
how much of a low-hanging fruit that
could be because yes we're interested in
long-term preventative health measures
but we're also interested in what could
we do in the short term to be able to do
it
so what are the points that the report
made I hope reasonably clearly is that
we have had an extraordinary Improvement
in air pollution over the last 30 to 40
years
and the two things that drive that
broadly are engineers and politicians
it's it's a combination of those those
two groups uh who can can lead on this
so if you take transport for example
um every decade the amount of uh
nitrogen oxides and particulate matters
has gone lower through cars as we move
to electrification nitrogen oxidizing
transport will virtually disappear uh
from at least the the light vehicle
Fleet there will still be used to use a
particulate matter from breaks and
particularly tires and they need to be
dealt with but there have been
significant improvements that have been
major improvements in industrial
emissions of air pollutants uh but uh we
have not had the same kind of
improvements in agriculture and that's a
that's not a trivial issue but probably
not one at this point in the the inquiry
but I think might be worth coming back
to
uh what we have not done so effectively
um in my view is uh tackle indoor air
pollution
and since that's where 80 of when people
where people spend their time in
industrialized countries that's a major
issue but largely the problem there is
one of we don't know what to do yet the
science is not settled whereas for
outdoor air pollution we do know what to
do and I think a lot of it is about
accelerating down the curve doing things
that we know will work including for
example speeding up electrification of
vehicles and variety of other things I
go through for the layperson listening
then what's a driver of indoor air
pollution well indoor revolution has got
intensity's got uh it's got three kind
of drivers it's got the stuff coming in
from the outdoors and that's why
tackling outdoor air pollution is
essential Because unless you've got that
you open the windows things get worse
it's got indoor air pollution created in
the home and that can be as simple as
things like the wrong sorts of air
fresheners people who want to know that
but then there's also ventilation and
here we've got a significant challenge
because we both want to have good
ventilation it's good for reducing air
pollution as good reducing infection a
variety of other things but we also want
to retain heat particularly in Winter to
reduce our carbon footprint to reduce
people's bills and those two are
potentially in conflict and we therefore
got to find engineering solutions back
to Engineers to actually get those two
resolved so that we can simultaneously
have good ventilation to reduce air
pollution and retain heat that is that
is a manageable engineering challenge
but it's it's one we haven't fully
resolved at this point okay
it's funny then Jonathan Maron I'm
obviously the CMO can talk and does big
picture in his annual report one of the
things that your organization is doing
is working with our integrated air
systems
how much of a focus do you push through
those local systems in uh in judging
their work on tackling poor air quality
working with the asses through our
regional directors and our national
teams we need to kind of put prevention
at the heart of their agenda I think
it's really encouraging to see just how
far the ICS leadership are taking uh
prevention I think we have probably
focused much more on secondary
prevention today you know what is it the
NHS can do can really make sure we do
the basics right have we found the
people with hypertension are they
effectively managed are reducing the
risk of stroke perhapses I think we're
then in our broader conversation with
local government we are interested in
what are the policies that help reduce
air pollution how can we work on
planning traffic schemes the broader
range of things that may help locally as
well as of course support and CMO in
this broader drive to have better
Solutions and less pollution created by
transport over the longer term okay
thanks all right I'm going to bring in
uh colleagues now and we'll go around
the tables with James Morris thank you
chair
which I thought it was interesting in
your initial Exposition that you didn't
mention mental health uh in relation to
prevention it was all about physical
health
um what am I like to read into that
so I think that the area of mental so if
you think about prevention of disease
I think we have a very good idea about
how to reduce many cancers
cardiovascular disease for example
we have much less of an idea about how
to do this in mental health but there
are things we do know do work and uh Dr
Gucci and I
worked with the Royal College of
psychiatrists and others to actually try
to identify which areas we already have
evidence of it things we can actually
improve the rates of people getting
mental ill health or if they have them
how frequently they then relax and come
back because that's often for many
severe particularly severe mental
illnesses these are relapsing remitting
conditions
but I think we should be clear that
although there are some things that we
know work uh the list is much less
secure for mental health than it is for
physical health my view very firmly is
that there probably are many things we
can do but they have not yet been
identified and I think this is this
should be a major area of research but
that doesn't mean we shouldn't get on
and do the things that we know do work
at this stage so on that the
historically
um during the per 2010-2015 there was
um the first time ever the formulation
of a five-year forward view for mental
health including stuff to do with
prevention now the government launched a
10-year plan consultation last year but
now has now said it's going to fold it
all into the major conditions strategy
so in terms of prevention of mental
health what do you think about that
well I think the uh I mean from my point
of view in a sense the vehicle that
ministers choose to kind of package
things in I think is very much one for
them uh rather than for me what I
certainly think we should definitely not
lose sight of is the fact that mental
health is in relative terms increasing
in importance and therefore preventing
this is getting more important as time
goes by now this isn't necessarily an
absolute increase in mental health
problems although we definitely had that
for some people during the uh the
lockdown period which might be worth
coming back to
um but uh what because physical health
has improved so much in many areas due
to prevention as much in large part
the relative contribution of mental
health issues is much greater than it
would have been 20 to 30 years ago so
therefore getting this being lost would
be disastrous and I think within that we
know that the mental health service is
one of the most stretched within the NHS
so the treatment end of it is uh
probably one of the most wretched areas
of the NHS before we get to the fact
that the prevention is much less well
evidenced so I'm going to ask Janelle in
a second if that would be helpful to go
through some of the things we did with
the Ross College
um but the the my view on this is the
most important period that we need to be
concentrating on is children from sort
of mid-childhood through to the middle
of their first their 20 their mid-20s
because the majority of people who have
mental health problems they will first
emerge during that period before we go
on to that because it's just on the on
the issue to do with the
interrelationship between mental and
physical health obviously there's often
complex dependencies isn't one of the
issues that kind of prevention Pathways
within our health system are still
predominantly about physical health and
the mental health causality is often not
addressed as part of that pathway if
that's the right way yeah I completely
agree with that and of course they go in
both directions so um
people with physical health problems are
more likely to have mental health
problems and that goes right back to pre
the prenatal period equally people who
have existing living with mental health
conditions can very often have much
higher rates of physical ill health
people with severe mental health
conditions very often die much earlier
not directly of mental health issues but
because they have greater rates of
cardiovascular disease or cancers or
other things so the this this
interrelationship between physical and
mental health is complex and
bi-directional as you imply
Janelle do you want to talk about the
work we've done right yeah so I think
tackle what Chris has said about that
interrelationship between mental poor
health or mental disorders and physical
health it's it's really important
um so we know that mental disorders
contribute about 21 of Burden the global
burden of disease for uh England so
that's quite a large proportion of that
so when we're looking at tackling a
healthy life expectancy mental health
absolutely is a large part of that and
as Chris said the majority of those
disorders over a lifetime mental
disorders start in childhood young
adulthood and so
the workaround prevention is really
important in developing that evidence
base around prevention so we did the
work looking at the state of the
evidence base and where where we had
stronger evidence and so
um you know looking at perinatal
interventions looking at interventions
with parents these are strong parenting
programs home home visiting or the home
visiting and parenting programs but then
also school-based interventions looking
at things like bullying in schools
workplace interventions
and by by describing that um you know
around schools around workplace
um you can see that what we what you
have to look at is across different
sectors so it's it's it's very much
where we have to work across government
uh both National but also local to look
at ways in which we can prevent mental
disorder so I think that what what we do
in terms of ohid is looking at that
evidence base and then sharing it and
the ways in which we we share that
across uh government different
departments but also in terms of local
systems the rcs's but also local
government
just a kind of final question but in
terms of when you talked about 21 of the
disease burden as it were I think that
is a recognized figure but if you look
at the amount of money that is spent on
Mental Health prevention research and
whatever it's minuscule it really I mean
I think we spend what 12 13 billion
pounds a year on Mental Health Services
with the NHS that's for everything not
not specifically prevention
do you think that balance needs to
change uh kind of looking at the
internet why do we all give a view on
that because I think I think we would
all have quite strong views on this so
my view is firstly on the research side
I think there's a lot more we could do
it's been left behind for a long time
and I did a report with Paul Farmer
who's then in a CEO of mind uh some
about four or four years ago running
through why were the what are the
reasons why this had not happened and
where were the areas we could improve
there really is a lot we can do on the
research side Jonathan you might want to
talk about the NHS a bit Yeah so I don't
get it so I think uh DHS has recognized
the need to put more money to mental
health for long-term plan set out an
investment standard the mental health
services would grow more quickly than
the rest of the Health Service and that
indeed has happened I think the numbers
are back in 2015-16 we spent about 11
billion pounds on Mental Health by the
end of 21 22 that's up to 15 billion and
of course 500 million extra was made
available during the pandemic trying to
help improve those services so I think
uh very clear investment in mental
health care
um both in terms of the services for
severe and acute mental health but also
much broader access to psychological
therapies reaching a much wider range of
people and some interesting work trying
to put dedicated teams into schools
where I think we have over 300 teams now
so I think a real sense to try and grow
that and then oh it's also tried to do
some interesting things our behavioral
program unit that runs campaigns and
tools for the public produced the better
Everyman Mata campaigns is part of our
better health program that's had a has a
health and wellbeing plan that you can
download and follow
um 4.6 million people have done that two
out of three of them say that it's led
to improvements in their health and
well-being so maybe at that very early
stage rather than treating severe
illness but we are trying to find ways
of how do we have uh you know a broader
conversation about mental
good health as well as mental ill health
and other practical things we can do to
help people tackle these problems but
can I just add to that I mean mental
health colleagues very often talk about
parity the Steam and they're doing that
not because they think that they're too
high they think that there is an under
investment and under an appreciation of
the importance of what they do and I
think most people would share that view
I think it is absolutely Central
thank you very much right Rachel Moscow
thank you so much
um Professor Woody I want to ask you a
question I've heard you say a few times
today there are things we can do or
we'll do things but whether we look at
smoking alcohol drug use gambling and so
on you've also drawn out how there were
targeted marketing but also by companies
but also we've seen
a greater prevalence within areas of
socio-economic deprivation and my
question is really about going slightly
more Upstream so rather than targeting
particular behaviors resultant what are
the stress factors that we're looking at
which are driving people into taking up
lifestyle choices which are going to
harm the health
there is the reason why
um uh so I think there are slightly
different situations if you're talking
about I'll take three examples uh where
deprivation is very clearly linked to
worst health
um in the case of uh let's start off
with the case of um people living with
obesity which undoubtedly is heavily
segregated that way
um
this is often rather unhelpfully framed
as a well people are just making
individual choices actually if you go to
the areas where levels of obesity people
living in obesity are much higher the
range of choices people have both in
terms of what they can eat where they
can exercise a whole variety of other
choices are very very heavily
constrained
and uh you you still have a situation
where people are essentially you can you
you might for example go up at High
Street one chicken shop after another no
that's not a single out Chicken Chops
particularly but just to make the point
that the range of choices that are
available in much more affluent areas
are simply not there and the facilities
are simply not there then you actually
have the reality that
um the marketing from some companies and
I will will pick out the cigarette
industry uh clearly is marketed heavily
at people living in areas of deprivation
because that is where they get their
customer you can see that from the
numbers they go for people in areas of
deprivation they go for for teenagers
that is their not that is their model uh
and so it's not therefore surprising if
there's very heavily marketing by some
of the most sophisticated marketing
companies in the world that you end up
in the situation you do
and then the final thing is that what
you have for many of these uh uh people
is multiple hits throughout their life
and if you look just to go back to the
example of the Blackpool
if you look at a map of Blackpool aged
about four
the ill health is distributed relatively
evenly across the city
by the age of 10 you already see really
heavy concentrations of ill health in
particular parts of the of the city
which then maintain for the rest of
someone's life and the the people who
die early come live in those same areas
of the uh the the the the the city what
I think this means uh for us in
prevention terms therefore is we know
where the problems are you can see them
on a map flashing very very firmly and
the same areas that were affected by
kovid were affected by are affected by
obesity and depressingly if you go back
to the 1860s the same areas very often
had the highest child mortality so these
are areas which have got deeply
entrenched Health deprivation but
therefore we know where we are those are
the areas we should go to intervene
because these are identifiable and we
should be able to therefore say if this
is where the big preventable problems
are let's put them put the biggest great
amount of our effort into these areas
because this actually is where the
problems are going to be fixable most
quickly
thank you and I completely conquer with
that and my constituency we have a
10-year life mortality
um differential so I I certainly
recognize that
um I'm particularly interested
um building on on the things that you've
highlighted about the roles of local
government in being able to bring out
sizable change and it seems to me that I
mean if we look we're still waiting for
the public health Grant this year
um one year grant funding so we're not
really thinking ahead and really
bringing in the seismic change which is
needed to address these inequalities and
of course we only have five percent
spent of the health Budget on public
health so what changes need to be made
to really drive that focus on those
communities which are
plate placed in the place of deprivation
because of the the system because of the
the circumstances around us and how do
we lift the priority and the work of for
instance directors of Public Health to
have more Force within the local
government environment our last doctor's
degree should you come into a second
because she was a director of Public
Health until very recently so I think
she's in a very strong position to give
her own experience with that I think the
issue is I mean we still have not got
the public health Grant quite over the
line I'm hoping that's coming very soon
but I think we would all accept that
local authorities in my experience and I
see a lot of them around the country do
an absolute extraordinary amount of work
with the resources they have I think
with more resources I think all of them
say they could do more but they're very
inventive in the way that they try to
create the healthiest environment for
their citizens and they are usually very
good at understanding exactly what the
local problems are down to the
individual street level and trying to
improve on those but I think there is a
lot more we could do locally and I think
most of us welcome the fact the public
health went back into local authorities
I think that had has many advantages but
of course they do then need to have the
resources and the political also the
political buy-in uh to be able to do
stuff again we're going back to the
point you need resource and you need
political uh buy-in as well Janelle do
you want to talk from your experience
yeah so
laid out how
um the places that where we live and
where we go to school and the houses we
live in and the nature of our
communities in terms of their housing
whether we can walk and cycle be active
access to healthier food or what kind of
food offer there is air quality all of
that is as you know really important in
terms of our health and well-being and
it really impacts in terms of those
conditions that we're talking about you
know whether you are more at risk of
cardiovascular disease or cancer and
drives that
increased mortality in particular young
early Maternity in particular areas so
that life expectancy gap between some
areas and others and it really makes a
big difference so if we take we talked
about high the hot food takeaways in
deprived areas there would be five times
hot food takeaways in more deprived
areas than in my finance areas and so
your access to a health healthy food
choice is and more limited or you we
know that the 20 of most affluent Awards
have considerable more
um access to Green spaces so just your
mental health well-being being able to
be active then if you lived in a more uh
deprived areas where your access to a
garden is just not there so all of that
I think is is really important and so
the reason I've gone into a bit of
detail is because I think prevention and
primary prevention really does go across
government it's a lot of sectors and in
a local area that comes together in a
local Council directors of Public Health
but working with with other public
sector and private sector bodies will
will be shaping that environment and I
think that's really important
um there are sorry yeah I just wanted to
pick you up on a point and it is to do
with the funding because if we are
talking about year by year funding at
such a minimum level as well and as we
say six weeks time the public health
Grant hasn't yet been delivered we
cannot build a sustained agenda to bring
about the changes which are required and
the strategy we've got a fantastic
directory of Public Health in York but
just not being able to plan and be able
to commission those services and to
bring about that change is a real
frustration so I want you to take that
back but also I think we really need to
think long term about how we turn the
ship around in those areas of Greater
step profession and need do you know how
I talked to the director Public Health
all the time so I'm very aware of their
views which I think are entirely
reasonable
okay thank you Rachel
um we're going to try and stick to sort
of 10 minute slots per colleague or 20
for the next because it's two colleagues
together on similar topics and that way
we then get everybody in just as a
public health warning for my colleagues
um starting uh exemplary performance uh
from Lucy Allen and Martin day starting
with this thank you chair and thank you
uh Professor Chris witty for being so
passionate about health inequalities
because ever since I've been in
Parliament I've heard politicians
talking about the impact on healthy
lifespan and it in terms of actual
lifespan as well and what's frustrated
me most is that in 2016 there is amazed
in the steps of Downing Street and said
narrowing Health inequalities was her
top priority in 2022 sagitt then Health
secretary talked to the Royal College of
Physicians and said that that was his
priority all politicians are committed
to this so what are we doing wrong that
these red spots are flashing on the maps
that you were talking to in your opening
address
I'd first of all like to
um
Department part of my job which is
de-politicize this by making clear that
these red flashing areas on them on the
maps have been through parties of
multiple colors over a long periods of
time
I think a lot of Public Health has so
whereas Curative Services you can move
stuff around really quite quickly and
I'm a jobbing NHS doctor I know how you
can shift stuff around I know that other
people have been NHS workers as part of
their careers around the table as well
Public Health has to be seen as quite a
long-term uh Strand and I think one of
the things that this committee can help
do is create in a sense a
bipartisan view about these are the
fundamental things there will be areas
of disagreement but here are some
fundamental things everybody agrees on
and the Baton needs to be passed from
hand to hand uh irrespective of who
stands on the steps of Downing Street
quite sincerely intending to try and
improve the situation because these
problems can be done if they are salami
sliced away and this is the point I made
about the cardiovascular work
see they could for example improvements
on air pollution improvements on smoking
have been large numbers of small changes
one made after another and each one
contributes three percent but 103 adds
up to a very significant shift in risk
and so what we should be doing is is
essentially assembling all the things we
can do and hopefully over this year you
will do that and say look there's
actually pretty good agreement around
this all the tables on this let's get
together and say these are going to
happen kind of irrespective of who is
actually in power because the danger is
otherwise what you get is prioritization
moving around and that's no one's fault
so that's not that's not a criticism at
all it's just to make the point that
these are these should be seen as
long-term bets rather than things you're
going to get an immediate turn and turn
on a six points is the snap widening and
we're getting worse Health inequalities
but that's being masked because Health
generally as a population is improving
but the inequality element is is getting
worse is that your view there is well
there are certainly parts of the country
where Health inequalities are getting
bigger uh it's not across the whole
country so this is I mean health is is
in terms of inequalities health is quite
local
and the variety can be quite
considerable and all the viewers can as
considered student cmps will know
there's a variety of areas within your
own boundaries uh generally so it is
quite local but in some areas it is
undoubtedly getting it is getting more
uh they're getting to be bigger
disparities between the uh the least
healthy and the most healthy the ones
that worry me most are not ones where
they're most healthy are getting even
healthier it's where the least healthy
are getting even unhealthier that really
is the one where that kind of is going
against all uh all of what all of us
would want to see
that's very helpful uh you mentioned
something about
um prevention being a long-term
something that 10 to 20 years
to see something coming through but I'm
just wondering if you could perhaps sort
of talk a little bit about
um how we change that mindset because if
we can get people to think about the
short-term uh benefits they're going to
be more likely
um to to implement those changes we had
Professor Chappelle the chief Scientific
Advisor giving us evidence on this a few
weeks ago and she said that we've got to
shift the mindset of thinking prevention
something to do with the long-term
future and make it relevant to now so
how do we make prevention relevant to
now well I think what we should do I
mean and I'm going to be deliberately
and slightly simplistic on this and
apologies I'm not I'm just trying to
make the point is there are some bits of
Public Health particularly when it comes
to Capital infrastructure
where you may get a relatively small
Improvement per year but once it's there
it's there forever and that might be a
legislative change or it might be a
cycle Lane but this is something where
actually you're seeing this as having a
huge long-term impact
and then there are some things which are
really quite fast so for example when
the ban on smoking in indoors public
areas came in there was a very rapid
reduction in heart heart attacks going
presenting a hospital within a year you
were seeing a very significant
reductions if you put someone that's in
the primary prevention airspace if you
put someone who's at risk of a stroke
who's hypertensive and anti-pertensive
the curves the sort of the curves on a
graph between those who are on treatment
and those who aren't Tarts are to
separate within six weeks so you
actually can start to see improvements
really very rapidly and of course they
compound one they compound very many of
them so you can actually over time have
really very large changes so I think
what we shouldn't see and I think people
wrongly think is that well I'm gonna do
all this investment now but we won't see
in advance an improvement for 20 years
there are some things where that is
probably true particularly improvements
in health in young adults who are
otherwise healthy but from very many of
the improvements particularly in later
life or in people who've already got
risk factors for example mental health
to go back to the first set of questions
the impacts can actually be really quite
rapid and I think we should we should
see that and most practitioners I think
would agree with that the the impact can
be really within months to years to a
small number of years
Jonathan I wonder if I could just ask
you about the um the office of Health
Improvement and what has been done to
tackle Health disparities
I think the those Health Improvement
disparities created October 21 so a
really deliberate decision to try and
bring the public health professionals
that have been in public health England
and the policymakers have been in the
Department of Health together into one
team
um we've run through quite a long
process of consultation and
and quite a little bit I think uh we we
all accepted that that was quite a big
change for a lot of people and a real
trade between a subset of Independents
which have been very very important
um to coming inside hoping to have more
influence and impact so I think what we
have tried to do is organize ourselves
to be uh
in the conversations about how to tackle
inequalities not as an outside external
body but as part of such a javed's team
uh Steve Barkley's team actually working
across White Hall lots of work with the
home office so I think uh
in terms of what have we done
um we've aimed to put the evidence the
best advice the opportunities in front
of our ministerial teams and actually
we've made some some really good
progress I mean the Obesity work uh
which got lots of attention over the
awesome period actually uh calorie
labeling and menus came in in the summer
the restrictions on uh
product placement in supermarkets uh
came in in October I mean really big
change I mean I don't know where you put
my shopping if only for the supermarket
to buy a lural or whatever those Mr
Kipling cakes on the end of the aisle
they were always very tempting and
they've gone
if I'm buying the cakes I know where
they are so that's kind of okay so we
just we've changed uh we're still
working advertising so look I think
there are quite significant changes have
happened and part of that's been that
we've had the people in the organization
to be able to have the conversation with
ministers uh with others about how we do
that like cross departmental work is
actually going on because yes because
it's not just about calorie counting no
no no no no no it's about housing and
planning and how we have our road system
so that we we walk and cycle and
absolutely and look I chose the uh the
Obesity examples partly because I mean I
think the coverage at the time suggested
we weren't doing anything at all and I
think you know the newspaper is always
very in One Direction don't they
um but not much wider worked on Chris's
work on air pollution of course we
worked across Whitehall looking at uh
work on that we've got work on roughly
papers with the
Department of local government we
working really hard with the ministry of
justice and home office on drugs and you
know really our drug users a really
marginalized community and we do a lot
to help with our health and lots of
investment going there so I think a
really broad brace base to our work uh
dcms and gambling uh obviously they're
not far away from their white paper we
hope so I think uh bringing us in has
definitely given better access to our
Public Health Specialists to the policy
makers in government which I think is a
good thing Angela and I have tried to do
a sort of lead or in a co-lead to show
that there's both the policies tradition
and the public health professionals I
think doing that together gives us
something that we haven't had before in
government thank you could I just add
one thing to that I mean just slightly
more childish one uh the problem for
many of these Pro these issues is that
the
um the bad side of things going badly
for public health ends up in health but
the cost of solving it is in a different
department yeah so let's say transport
the cost of actually putting in cycle
Lanes the podcast of doing all things is
in the transport both political cost and
financial cost the same would be true
for defra for some of the air quality it
sees
and really only at the end of the day
treasury in number 10 can actually say
this is a holy government problem and we
need to bring that together so it is
important for us to work with our
colleagues and we do I've been very
recently on on air pollution on Twitter
transport in defer but this has to be
these problems are whole of government
problems they're not they shouldn't be
seen as just a department of health
problems very important Point thank you
for that that is why Chris we have you
at the start of this inquiry because you
are the government's independent advisor
and you know you are yes you're
Secretariat I suppose comes through the
Department of Health and Social care but
you
um you know you work across government I
remember as a minister working with with
you and uh your predecessor in other
department within other departments and
that you know this this inquiry most
certainly looks beyond our realm as a
select committee because it would be it
wouldn't be credible if it didn't but so
thank you for saying that it really
helps us so Martin day connected
subjects yeah yeah very much on the same
territory as Lucia's been on I take a
great interest in food standards and
health and how it impacts on Obesity so
I think that there's a lot there and I'm
very concerned obviously about kl2 to
BCD in particular and you've spoken
about how hardwired the deprivation
seems to be in healthier which is is
flabbergasting to think that you could
trace that back to the 1800s in some
areas
um now my colleagues up in Edinburgh and
the Scottish government are trying to
have childhood obesity by 2030 and it
seems to me dealing only with the
consequences of poor diet and higher
weight isn't isn't enough we need to
tackle poverty and poverty is is such an
underlying Factor but as you've quite
rightly said that requires often a
political decision so I'll not ask you
to make a political comment but one of
the areas that I was interested in was
David B's national food strategy and I
wondered if you would
coming on the main components of that
and how rapidly we would see an impact
if we were to go down the different
Avenues of that
um you know he obviously promoted the
expansion of free School Meal program
for those on Universal Credit to tackle
food poverty and unhealthy thing it
covered expanding sugar and salt taxes
to fund fresh fruit and vegetables for
low-income families something I would
personally favor and it also called for
a 30 cut in meat consumption inside a
decade which would be a big cultural
change I think that we need to pull off
what how do each of those three factors
how rapidly would we see an impact from
each of them is what I'm asking uh thank
you well so um firstly just to
acknowledge the uh really great work
that is done in Scotland although I'm
speaking just on England and I'm the CMO
for England I talk every week and often
more than that to my opposite number Dr
craigo Smith and his uh his colleagues
Professor Gregor Smith as he now he's
actually Professor sir grego Smith I'm a
fantastic Public Health colleagues in
Scotland and learn a lot because
actually Scotland has blazed a trail in
many areas of Public Health that we've
learned from I hope the same is also
true in the other direction so there is
learning between the four nations of the
UK
um in terms of the the dimbleby report I
thought it was unfortunate to land at a
particular point when it was politically
quite difficult I think to give it the
concentration it deserved and I think
having a second look at this in this
committee would in fact be something
which would be really valuable I would
also commend the Khan review on smoking
I thought both of those were excellent
reports and actually deserved a bit of
time and political consideration as to
what are the things which are doable now
and what aren't
uh certainly I consider things of
Taxation are clearly absolutely for
political leaders to take decisions on
rather than public health people we can
say what we think the impact would be
but just to take the uh soft drink soft
drinks uh levy on sugar that was an
extraordinarily successful uh policy it
led to a 34 reduction in Sugar while
sales actually slightly increased in
every single segment of society so
there's something where actually
everyone wins the there's no
disadvantage to the marketplace and the
amount of sugar in the system
significantly goes down it was a
well-designed intervention that
essentially incentivized people to
reformulate there are many things which
could be done and this is the key is to
incentivize people to reformulate is not
to reduce choices and then to provide a
Level Playing Field and it's quite
interesting talking to Industry which we
obviously do that I've been quite strong
by how many of the political leaders are
expecting the industry to say please
give us no more regulations no
regulations and quite the reverse what
industry says we quite like to do this
but if you don't put a regulation in
place our competitors will try and
undercut us so the regulation is simply
there to allow the people who want to do
it to do so without a competitive
disadvantage in the marketplace so there
are a lot of things that can be done
that work with the incense with the
trend of the market to reduce calories
to take that example from the menu
across a whole range of different things
I'm talking about an ultimate in a
restaurant sense in the sense of
whatever I need but and there's a big
but to this we have to be very careful
that in doing so we don't uh make food
more expensive for them for the least uh
wealthy in society so getting the
balance between a more nutritious diet
and one that doesn't become more
expensive is absolutely critical we've
got to get that balance right because
pushing deeper into food poverty would
be the would be the reverse of a good
Public Health intervention so that's an
example where you know a crude approach
to it would probably do some good but
also do some harm and working with
industry but also thinking seriously
through the poverty implications is
likely to be far more effective but as I
say regulation has a very major place
and that clearly has to be something for
political leaders to make a call on like
thank you very much mother is a question
again it it's one that requires a
political decision so but I don't expect
you to as I say give a political answer
but it seems to me that advertising must
affect public outcome and what they
expect to get and and you know we've not
had to buy one get one free deals on
junk food band and I think PM Watershed
or an advertising and advertising
something that Scotland doesn't control
so I need colleagues here to to grab
this one and do something
um
how much of an impact do you think
advertising actually has on people
making poorer choices
well I mean if advertising didn't make
an effect on people's behaviors then
people wouldn't pay the very large sums
they do for it I mean that's a
self-evidently true statement uh and so
um things which actually affect
advertising are particularly advertising
aimed at children and I think this is
the area where my colleagues and I feel
very strongly is children you know not
they are we as Society accept that we as
the adults particularly younger children
are taking choices for them advertising
at children is in a sense undermining
that principle and I do think uh there
is generally consensus about the fact we
need to do something about it I think uh
I'm reminded of the Saint Augustine
thing O Lord mainly holy but not yet uh
approach there is a slight tendency for
this this particular can to be kicked
down the road for a variety of reasons
my view is firmly that we should be
taking uh this some this thing seriously
because there is I think support around
the political system for it it's to do
with the timing and I think accelerating
the timing to me seems a good Public
Health intervention that runs very much
with the grain of most people's
philosophy irrespective of where they
sit on the political Spectrum
excellent a Saint Augustine quote in our
select committee doesn't happen every
day for that CMO uh Paul blomfield
thanks Steve
um I'm interested in
how we anticipate future risk so we've
talked a lot this morning about obesity
we weren't talking much about obesity
when it wasn't a problem or when it was
only an emerging problem in the past
um
as an example I mean Jonathan's
mentioned gambling
there was an NHS statement on The Today
program this morning about the probably
gambling addiction
we know that online gambling is bringing
about a generation of young gamblers
child gamblers which is kind of creating
a potentially massive future problem
now so I just wondered how you go about
not necessarily on that specific issue
but anticipating future risk so I'll
I'll do a futurist limit it might be
useful for Jonathan to comment on the
gambling thing because he's got he's
taken a lot of interest in that in that
I mean let's just take a a really
obvious example
um of uh the population aging in fact
I'm doing my annual report this year on
the Aging Society
um
you know everyone knows it's aging what
I think has been underappreciated in
policy terms is it's aging very very
unevenly across the country this is true
for all four nations in the UK instantly
but I'll just take the English data so
in England people move into cities at 18
usually through either study or work and
they move out typically after their
second child
meaning that the cities maintain their
demographics so
Birmingham Manchester Newcastle and
London will look very similar in 30
years to what they do now but the
equation has to balance and therefore
large parts of the country are growing
older far faster than the average would
imply North you know in England that
would be North Norfolk Devon um but
that's a Cumberland I mean those kind of
areas outside the city areas often
difficult areas to provide services for
but also difficult to provide some of
the preventative Services for
that's a completely predictable problem
which is going to hit us really hard if
we don't deal with it now
and therefore we need to be planning for
that future issue and interesting that's
going to change the geography of disease
because the big two big drivers of
preventable disease tend to be in areas
of deprivation and in areas of
concentrations of older people and it's
going to shift from some of the typical
areas of deprivation inner city areas at
post-industrial areas increasingly to
semi-rural areas coastal areas where in
fact you have higher concentrations yes
of relative poverty but also of large
concentrations of older citizens so
there's just an example of exactly the
point you're making that you have to
think 20 years ahead 30 years ahead
because a relatively modest change now
could have a really big impact over that
time frame if we wait until the
problem's on us it's going to be far
more difficult to do both politically
and financially and the infrastructure
will simply not be there uh Jonathan
you'll talk about the scrambling yeah so
I think before Jonathan comes in 100 I
can just press you a little bit on that
because I'm Keen to hear um specifically
on gambling but I mean that's do you
think that we are and that's a great
example
um that you gave but do you think we are
sufficiently good at anticipating future
risk on a wider scale I think we are
extremely good at anticipating and
admiring it
and considerably less good at then doing
something as a result
so uh so I think in a sense
very important in this committee that
you both identify the problems but also
I think push
me and others a bit on okay so what are
the solutions to that because that is
the way the difficult choices come is
what we're going to do about this and
having anticipated it
yeah because well when um same old's
last answer I'm thinking hard what I say
next um so gambling I think the really
interesting thing uh there's some
generalized points here that there's a
really important surveillance in having
the data looking at you know are we
seeing how and we've done lots of work
on uh survey work uh just understanding
the impact uh so as uh in this case as a
gambling environment's changed we think
people become more worried about uh what
we're seeing in the surveillance data
phe actually is our predecessor uh did
some really detailed work on do we
understand the evidence of harm in
gambling that's been I think really
helpful in uh gaining attention and
people really understanding that look
whilst many people might have you know
the odd flutter or whatever is perfectly
harmless actually there's a significant
portion of the population that has uh
you know much more harmful uh gambling
uh behaviors and we do something about
that so we've worked both on uh if you
like the surveillance and the basic data
the evidence of the harm to bring it
together and then also actually do we
understand that the different drivers or
we are expecting a white paper shortly
out of dcms so it's not my department so
I'm not totally sure of the timeline but
uh we're close uh and they're really
thinking about well what changes do we
need in the regulator environment uh to
help make a gambling safer I think
that'll look at everything from you know
the design of games uh how do people get
the marketing work uh and then through
to actually either is there more we can
do on education
um and perhaps treatment to try and
mitigate the effects of some of the harm
so I think a very broad canvas and just
to give sort of an easy to understand
example here I think that many people
remember the fixed odds betting
terminals uh you know games spin around
people running uh large amounts of money
people get very worried about those very
obviously driving a a much higher level
of harm so we've changed the uh the
government change the amount you could
win and that's that's made a nice
difference so I think some of these
things are technical are the ways the
game's structured leading to harm and
can we do that there there's some things
about marketing and then also have we
got the right treatment so I think the
story today was around the the NHS now
got eight specialist Regional treatments
looking at gambling diction uh promising
up to 15 hopefully by the end of 2023.
so I think you know as we've become more
aware of the issues we've also managed
to get the treatment moved under a much
longer ingest response than we had about
six years ago
thanks very much
um and if I'll ask us a kind of sort of
linked question about
um whole government approach across
developmental working
um I mean we we touched just another
example I mean we touched on Mental
Health earlier in child Mental Health
um I was shocked when I was in ump going
into schools talking to kids about what
they thought my priorities should be
that top of their agenda was access to
Mental Health Services
push them further on what the
shoes were
um that they thought were driving their
mental health problems and I was equally
surprised by that because I probably had
an old person's view about such media
and and so on and they said
no it's actually the pressure that we're
under from schools and our parents to
achieve academically
now how do you open up that discussion
um and developing a whole government
approach
uh well I'll have a go at that I mean
that's not an easy question actually
because the question about how fast
schools should push has been I mean that
goes back centuries uh to be honest
um and exactly what about the right
balance is between going so hard too
hard and going not hard enough but the
schools is the bit which actually is
under the control of the state and
therefore the state has to take a view
on this
um what we know that just to take the
public health approach we know that on
the one hand the stresses are being
pushed too hard have potential mental
health consequences we also know that
there is a very strong correlation
between good education and having a long
education and having less Dementia in
later life just on the public health
leaving aside success and so on so you
do have a balance even narrowly taking
the public health implications of this
now this is not one for us as public
health people to say that the point
along the graph should be here but it's
very much one which I think Department
of Education and government as a whole
has to say at this point in it in
history have we got that balance right
and if what we're getting from students
is a different a view that things are
considerably more stressful than they
were maybe when we were all at school
that's probably something for us to
listen to and take seriously I think one
of the things you learned very early in
public health is listening to what
children say themselves
is usually a lot more informative than
trying to imagine back yourself back to
how you were at that age and trying to
legislate in good faith uh on that basis
things have moved the the experience of
childhood is quite different now to what
it was uh 20 30 years ago
you think that um I mean we're quite
good at beginning to develop prostitute
but mental working on some of the issues
of physical health
I mean a lot more to be done clearly
from everything you've said do you think
that's at the same stage in terms of
mental health no I don't think there's
anywhere near the same stage and that's
partly because for physical for
certainly for let's say exercise
I don't think you'd find anybody in
Parliament I would guess who doesn't
agree that more exercise for children is
a good thing in providing them with
facilities is a good thing I mean I made
it wrong but I they did a minority view
that's for sure
and the evidence for that is good and it
runs with this kind of the thrust of
what most people believe anyway for
mental healthy evidence is much less
strong
and the interventions are probably more
contested
and issues like should we go easier on
public exams for example actually has
snakes as well as ladders on the on the
board in a way that providing better
playing facilities does not so it's a
much harder area to deal with but for
the reasons that Mr Morris said right at
the beginning you know this is something
we're going to have to Grapple with
because it is an increasing part of the
uh the issues of Health in general and I
you know ultimately Society is
represented by Parliament so I think at
the end we can provide some bits of the
jigsaw the education can provide
something to explore but the decisions
have to be taken here in a local
government that's really fundamentally
where the final calls got to be made
can I can I add a small pizza it's not
an answer to the whole question but just
on schools so these the mental health
schools based teams is a joint an
Institute between the department of
health insurance department for
education so I did start a piece of work
of the Departments together looking at
we're not doing enough to provide
support to Children our schools and
coming up with a sort of a joint and
jointly managed solution to that now
we've rolled that out to about I think
about quarter of schools at the moment
the program is still ongoing so you know
some start of trying to join up but I
think you're asking a much bigger
question then that answers
thanks very much that's fascinating yeah
very briefly and we're going to go very
briefly but a very big question for it
hopefully it's a brief answer
um we're very aware of the enormous
scope of this inquiry
what do you think the most effective
thing we could do is in terms of our
focus and that's not necessarily what's
the most important issue
but what could we most effectively shine
a light on uh well I I I'm gonna give
you two answers which you can interpret
as you wish the first one uh is from
Health Improvement which is the
non-communicable side uh the bits of
Health Improvement prevention that can
really be decided on by parliament are
primary prevention
so it seems to me although there's a lot
of really important stuff on secondary
prevention that's largely around
resource allocation in the NHS
but this is a primary prevention or
around society's choices so given that
this is a parliamentary inquiry my view
is the primary prevention questions the
things which society which Parliament
decides local authorities decide is a
very major issue to consider the second
one which is on the health protection
side which we haven't talked much about
which is preventing infectious problems
pandemics and also emergencies like
nuclear and chemical and so on uh we've
just had an example of the power of
nature
to cause absolutely catastrophic Public
Health implications
the past experience has been that every
time we're in the middle of one everyone
says why do we not invest properly why
did we not take this seriously
and between events people forget how bad
it was and disinvest in all these areas
and because the most urgent things come
up so I think not forgetting the power
of Health protection to prevent the
worst excesses of nature in public
health for emergencies is possibly
another area you might want to go into
as I say we haven't discussed it so far
this morning I'm just putting on the
table since you've asked me you mean
planetary factors or do you mean uh
covid uh what I mean covert was an
example of that there are planetary
factors as well
um but but certainly some environmental
issues would be in that space But I was
thinking specifically about emergencies
of which infectious ones are the most
common but you also have to think about
the things like nuclear chemical as well
as part of this and just the danger is
we always between events under invest
not because we're intending to everyone
agrees is important but because urgent
things happen and the hospitals are full
and the anes are and you want to get
more ambulances and you want to get more
social care and the salami slicing of
the public health emergency budget into
that and I'm not saying it's going to
happen this time all I'm going to say
what I'm saying is historically that is
what has always happened between events
and that might be worth something that
they're worth just thinking through with
uh with colleagues when their Witnesses
in front of you very very good point
does previous performance indicate
future Direction
Dr Caroline Johnson
thank you uh good morning
um whose responsibility is it to keep us
healthy
well I think uh the the answer is it's a
tripartite
um uh answer in my view I think there's
a bit of
um uh it which is around individuals
making their own choices everyone would
agree with that
there's a bit of it um which is around
uh what government can do and there are
situations where people
um think government should do that and
the situations that people think
government should not do that and the
third bit is uh the healthcare
Professionals in the world of sense now
the healthcare professionals bit is the
second prevention side and I'll come
back to that if you want but that's in a
sense that's the most neatly defined my
view is that where the uh the most
people the revealed preference and I
would take this as what people have
historically expected is where either
there's an emergency there's always been
an assumption the government should do
something in emergencies coming back
Millennia which infectious emergencies
are the most obvious but floods
tragedy of the of the earthquakes in
Turkey are examples how do you recover
better than that from health so that's
always been something areas where uh
there's a there's something that's in
common so for example air pollution I
can't prevent much certainly outdoor air
pollution myself affecting my family
that's got to be a societal thing
that's either done by
government representing Society was done
by nobody
you can't as an individual choose the
air pollution level you've got that's a
societal choice and protecting the most
vulnerable so particularly protecting
children pregnant women and work
again long history of you shouldn't die
just because you've gone to work that
day and the government has a role in
preventing the power imbalance between
an employer an employee deployed person
so if you take an example
um I think that the great majority of
things the average person in the country
would be very clear either I expect
government to do this I expect it to
make sure my food is safe I expect it to
keep the air clean I expect it to make
sure that cars are not going to drive
into me because they're not properly
inspected or I expect government to stay
one out of it yes a child might fall off
a rock
side because they've gone rock climbing
that's nothing to do with the state you
know Banning Suites is nothing to do
with the state we might want to
encourage people to have fewer of them
but so there's a kind of the things
which I think my view is the great
majority of the public are clear either
we want
government to intervene or we want
government not to intervene and then
there's a small bit in the middle which
is contested which could go either way
and that's where political Traditions
tend to play although it's not an
obviously right left one to be clear
it's often much more to do with where
people put that balance and you know the
the relative balance of individual
freedom to make your own mistakes
against the government's responsibility
to put a safety net under people for The
Most Dangerous Ones is on both the left
and the right of politics that is so I
want to be clear I don't think this is a
left right thing and I think those are
the most difficult ones in many ways
politically because the you could answer
the question either way and often what
you're doing is you're trading off very
very difficult uh
um uh things in either direction so I
think my view is that's the most
difficult area but nobody would disagree
that everybody has an individual
responsibility and of course no one will
disagree that the Health Professions
have that's part of what they're paid
for
thank you so that's sort of the balance
between authoritarian and libertarian
sort of the mindsets
um
what about the environment that some
people are living in in Blackpool is an
example that you gave and you talked
about the chicken shops and the
difficulties in accessing food or open
spaces and such things but within these
areas there are still people who are
living healthy lives it may be more
common to be unhealthy but it isn't
Universal
so what evidence do we have about what
incentivizes or what drives the people
who will remain healthy even within more
challenging areas to remain so and how
can we we can expand those behaviors I
guess to a wider population within those
areas okay well I have a first go on
this and then I'll
maybe ask Janelle to talk about the fact
that she's had to do this live this in
as a director of Public Health and as
president of the association of director
of Public Health
um
I think that the thing which we
shouldn't do is assume that the problem
that most people have is a lack of
knowledge
so the average smoker knows that smoking
is bad for them the average person who
is living with obesity knows that that
is bad for their health
so it's not that they don't know
something
so why have they actually got to that
situation well to take those two
examples they have largely got to that
situation because that is the Pres that
is what has been presented to them as
attractive choices either by marketing
or simply availability that is just a
reality so why is the population
collectively got a lot heavier over the
last 30 years is not because humans are
different humans to what they were 30
years ago but the way in which the
market is structured and the way they
can interact with it has changed over
that time that period of time
now of course within that there are
individual choices there are also
biological things some people have got a
different set point in terms of when do
they feel full rather than not when
they're eating for example that's
genetically determined as well as
socially determined it's a complex
interaction and then they have the
choices that are put in front of them so
these things are always quite complex
I think what we have to work out is when
in a sense when is the the the
uh the plate being so firmly tilted
against them that it is the job of
society to try and level it a bit and
when is it it's just purely a matter of
their own choice and which goes fine
and I think what people the more you
look at the reality of it the reality
for most people is that the choice who
are living in more areas of deprivations
their choices are quite heavily
constrained
and it's not fair to say to them but
it's all you know it's your choice
you've chosen to do this when in fact
the menu of choices they were given was
a pretty constrained menu of choices so
I think we have to be honest about with
ourselves that for some people the range
of choices is far wider than for others
and the more constrained people's
choices are the more it is reasonable
that the state at least asks the
question should we actually do something
to help uh redress that that doesn't
answer it it just simply says that is a
legitimate question to ask whereas if
someone's got an infinite Infinity of
choices before them then to some extent
that's kind of up to them
okay you think I wanted to ask you about
vaping
you've talked about tobacco smoking and
we know that we want to stop people to
making tobacco because it's bad for them
and makes them die younger of all sorts
of different diseases
um
and so then this has been invented as
vaping that you can um you can stop
smoking more effectively we believe it's
less bad for you it's evidence that's
less bad for you than smoking but we
also know it's not as good for you as
breathing fresh air
and one of my concerns is that something
which was supposed to be a stops making
device like nicotine gum has become a
fad heavily marketed at children which
is developing an a whole generation of
teenagers completely addicted to sucking
little nicotine sort of colored pop
things
um what's your thoughts on the effects
on the teenager's health of this vaping
and how do we um stop them from getting
addicted so I think that um let's let's
start off with the bits of the the
puzzle that everybody agrees on and then
I'll zero on the bits where I think it's
more contested because but I think let's
start off with the agreement everyone
agrees I think that uh it is far safer
for someone to vape than to smoke
so if the choice has to be between one
or two of those there are smoke they're
smoking heavily now they want to come
off smoking and they can move on to
vaping they can't just go completely
stop then that is a net benefit in
health terms and vaping has an important
role as a public health tool to help
smokers who are addicted through often
no choice of their own at this stage to
come off smoking so I think I think
everyone agrees with that I think
everyone agrees that marketing vaping a
an addictive product with as you imply
unknown consequences for developing
Minds
uh to Children is utterly unacceptable
yet it is happening there's no doubt
it's happening because although from a
low base the rates of vaping have
doubled in the last couple of years
among children so that is an appalling
situation
and then there's a bit in the middle
which is uh is it reasonable to have in
any case flavors and colors that are
clearly aimed at essentially encouraging
people to vape who may well not be
vaping at all because absolutely much
rather people don't Vape at all than uh
than not it's only those who are already
smoking where vaping is the root out for
them where vaping has a clear Public
Health goal so I think that uh where
that leaves us is I think we need to be
much more uh serious in my view and I
know this is very firmly something you
have championed and I completely agree
with you that trying everything we can
to reduce smoking uh sort of vaping in
children as well as smoking in children
both of those are critical is really
important whilst trying what we can do
to make sure that the vaping is
available for those for whom that is the
route out of smoking for which it is the
best they by no means a
wholly effective but by far the best
tool for some people so it's getting
that balance right and there's quite a
lot of debate around the country the
world how to do this I think something
you have picked up on Dr Johnson and I
completely agree with you is disposable
Vapes are clearly for things like
elsewhere are clearly the kinds of
products which look as if they're being
marketed in reality at children and I
think we should look very seriously at
these products for which the child
Market appears to be the Principal
market and say why are we considering
this to be a good thing to have
[Laughter]
thank you excellent thank you
um right Paula Hamilton it's you oh good
morning
um sir sir Chris witty
um my question is quite a simple one
while I worked in local governments I
did an awful lot of work with public
health side by side and in many
instances had the pleasure of actually
speaking to yourself online and others
problem I have with o h i d with public
health England moving into the
Department of Health and and Social
Security I hear what Mr Moran says about
the fact that you've got the policy
makers
I'm concerned that you're not as
reactive so you're not as proactive so
you're not reacting to things as quickly
as you need to and I'll give an example
or I'll give a couple if it will help
we have an issue with teenage pregnancy
now teenage pregnancy clearly sits
within ohid the problem with then have
is it also links quite closely with
sexual transmitted diseases of young
people now that's with the health
Security Agency the question I need to
ask to to get across is if we truly want
prevention how are these two things
lining up that's my first question and
my second question is do you agree or
disagree with me and I'm leading that
perhaps I'm not gonna do it thanks for
them
I feel with all the changes that have
happened since the height of kovid that
you um have lost your voice and in turn
what oh ID is doing as has lost their
voice where we want them to be more
proactive in what they're doing and then
my last point because I'm going to do it
just and you can answer as you see fit I
have this thing about the Nitric nitrous
oxide you know the thing that young
people they sniff and there is a p there
is an absolute clear link that it leads
to Ms in in an older age that's what
people are saying because it strips
um the muscles or something this is what
the research is saying the problem is at
the moment we cannot get
um oh ID or anybody to actually come out
and make a clear statement on it so we
see a potential disaster that is
happening with our young people going
forward but at the moment we are
absolutely struggling to to get the
powers that be you guys who have the
power to actually make the clear
statements which would help both locally
and help us as politicians to set a
clear Direction over to you Doctor um
thank you very much thank you very much
what I suggest is I'll give a couple of
answers to that but actually ohid is
very much led by Janelle Jonathan so I
suggest that they really lead on on on
this answer uh firstly um have we lost
our voice well I mean I think several
people around the table actually would
probably argue out people people like me
not through any tension of our own had
too big a voice in the last two years so
uh that I mean in a sense that was an
atypical period
um uh of time uh because it was an
emergency and I think what we're getting
back to is a more typical uh environment
and I personally think that's actually
probably quite a good thing uh overall
um
but ohit itself I think has a bigger
Voice Within government than it did
for which the trade is a bit less
ability to actually say from the outside
government you're not doing this right
your government you're not doing that
right that is that is the reality that
is the trade and uh Jonathan has rightly
said the positive side of it which is
his job I'm just making the point that
actually there are in fact a there is
there are you know there's a balance on
this but I think my view have to say
independently is that oh here does have
more influence within government than it
did when it was part of Public Health
England which was outside but there was
no perfect solution for it which is why
this has moved around at various points
there isn't an absolutely perfect answer
to this in terms of the interaction
between teenage pregnancy and sexually
transmitted infections
um well firstly there has been and we
should really acknowledge and this is
largely led by education there has been
a significant reduction in teenage
pregnancy over time and that's a real
that's got so many benefits for the
women involved for their children for
long-term things so that has been a big
improvement over some decades this again
this has gone over uh governments of
different colors if I can put it that
way uh
the link with STIs
um I mean the the recent mpocs outbreak
we had in the UK demonstrated that STIs
are a very serious issue and sexual
behaviors are part of that's part of the
more complicated areas something I have
to remind some of my colleagues is the
last really severe
um uh pandemic we had was HIV it's
actually transmitted so a sexually
transmitted root can be a very a route
to a very serious infection uh uh and
the some of the earliest bits of the NHS
were set up largely to deal with the
fact that the UK had a major syphilis
problem 100 years ago and needed to deal
with that one in 10 men in London I had
syphilis for example quite extraordinary
when we look back on it so uh bringing
together the various components I think
is critical I have a line both to ohid
on the non-communical stuff and to the
ukhsa in fact my own background I'm an
infectious disease physician by trade so
I very much see the links between these
but I think if you or anyone feels you
think there's disconnect between the
non-communical and the communicable you
should flag it because that is a really
serious thing if that goes wrong
that was the 10 one of the potential
benefits that the he system I have to
say and Jonathan can say whether he
agrees he used to work in it I'm not
sure it always worked even when they
were in the same building the
philosophies were quite different so I
think I wouldn't say any disconnect is
necessarily just due uh to the fact that
in a building's about five minutes walk
away uh I think that that seems to me
probably not the principal reasons for
the cultural differences that sometimes
arose say if you disagree Jonathan
Janelle do you want to give an answer
yeah should I go next Jonathan and then
you come in yeah so I I think
um
uh thanks for that and uh certainly I
mean what I would uh want to do is
emphasize the importance of the director
Public Health role
um and we've talked about that before
and having been a dph and I know
um strong directors to Public Health in
uh your area as well
um and so that that role of the director
of Public Health is really really
important in in knowing what the
um what's happening on local population
uh local population health and where
it's the same as National but also where
it might be different and what what
those concerns are so it's really
important and so
um knowing about that and then thinking
about well what we can do and local
directors of Public Health are very good
at looking across systems and ensuring
that they can
um find that system leadership in a
local area between Council Council
Services the services that they
commission so Sexual Health Services
with those Services provided and
commission commission and provided
through NHS for example and so I think
icps are a real opportunity to look at
how can we do this differently because
we know that Sexual Health reproductive
Health
that really this is one area I think
where we need to do better at
integration
and so so I think that's that's really
important in terms of oh here we've got
regional directors of Public Health and
I I directly line manage the regional
directors of Public Health so there will
be one in the Midlands so again with
that line of sight as to what's going on
in local areas what what issues might be
arising of particular concern and then
looking for Solutions at either Regional
or local area or whatever the the
geography makes the nuisance because
they've only got 10 minutes but um my
view is I feel as if we're losing that
independent voice So within your answer
could you just tell me how do you feel
going forward we will keep that
independent voice so some of those
emerging issues is not just tied up
within local systems and then it's got
it's an emergency as you've talked about
or something that has gone wrong we then
hear what is going on and the example I
gave was that nitrous oxide which is a
major issue at the moment in areas like
the area I'm from but for some reason we
can't get
the people above to to even make a
statement on it because if it's
happening in Birmingham it's got to be
happening elsewhere that's all I'm
saying so yeah
um
I think I'll I'll
hand over to Jonathan shortly but I
think
um for me it's it's that that that that
relationship or making sure that we hear
what's going on in Birmingham and as I
say through I think that is really
important because then that Voice
through to the regions but also to
National Chris has mentioned we still
have calls with local directors of
Public Health regular calls so that we
can have that local intelligence and
alert to us I don't know that specific
issue that you're highlighting in terms
of nitrous oxide I think
we'll make a guarantee that we will we
will provide a paper on that yeah and at
the end of that if it's clear enough if
the data is clear enough we will say
something reasonably clear about it I
think it's a very fair challenge but I
don't think that's to do with where it
sits I think that's to do with we
haven't concentrated on that issue it's
a good one to raise should we do you
want to very briefly go that on the
night so I point or was that was there
something else very briefly I think just
in a minute there's a couple things
together so whilst we've brought
our Public Health colleagues into the
department we're really clear that we're
no change to what they're able to
publish so we're going to speak to the
evidence we continue to publish produce
over 200 statistical reports so that's a
valence function that PhD had which is
really important stays the ability of
our professionals to talk about what's
happening on the ground stays
um but we might be having a slightly
different conversation about government
policy where we're in the policy
discussion rather than trying to
influence from outside so I think that's
where we've got a change I think that's
making a difference nitrous oxide is
something that's live in government
we're talking to the home office the
Department of Health uh people share
your concerns about you know as Chris
offers we're happy to help when you say
it's a live issue in government I mean I
go out with the litter Pickers in my
constituency and I constantly find the
little capsules that Paul is talking
about yes and uh Neil O'Brien's very
concerned about these doctors College in
the home office we you know it's an
issue that people are uh turning our
attention to yeah and and thank you all
for your responses that nitrous
um oxide issue there is a link if you
I'm a social media iPad there is a link
that they say with MS and the fact that
young people are starting to present
with early onset of Ms well that's why I
asked the questions
yes correct so could I just make a very
clear point on that because I think your
point you raise the nitric acid is a
good example of this my viewers if the
evidence is clear you can be inside
government dioxide government the
evidence speaks for itself
where it tends to be more tricky is when
the evidence is pretty unclear and
there's a certain amount of advocacy
involved but if the evidence is clear
you simply say well here's the evidence
and then I think that then leads then
there has to be a response either we
cannot ignore it or when you do
something but at least that makes it
clearer so I think it's assembling the
evidence we need to do okay great
homework uh Chris Green
uh Professor Whitty now I'm just going
to look at town planning uh for a short
while so a good few years ago a lot of
towns were designed but like Milton
Keynes I think as Lucy Allen would
highlight uh parts of Telford design
where it's quite an urban sprawl you've
got these roundabouts it doesn't lend
itself to active travel it doesn't lend
itself to public transport either and
once these things are built once these
towns are built there for
decades or hundreds of years in that
format it's very difficult to change
them and at the moment we're going
through a thing where there's a lot of
focus on 15-minute cities which I'm not
very comfortable about this certain
surveillance aspects and other control
aspects but I'm far more sympathetic to
everything being in Walking distances so
what's your view in terms of these Grand
designs and sometimes the potential for
them going wrong because you don't quite
envisage what's coming down the line in
a few years but I mean I I engage as as
Janelle does and uh and dph is
definitely do with these for example the
chief planner a lot because you can
build in either good health or ill
health
and as you say once it's done it's very
difficult to undo and this is true both
at the macro level so planning a city or
adjusting it as time goes by and at the
micro level so for example one of the
reasons we're going to have a problem in
the UK as the population gets older is
the housing stock is not designed for
that it's designed for young family with
two children uh largely and that's going
to be very problematic so people with
even moderate disability may not find it
easy to live independently so I'm just
using so the design of the built
environment and the also the natural
environment that we maintain within it
is absolutely critical for physical
element that goes in with the point of
Manchester Birmingham London maintaining
the population age range and more
people people are going to be moving
towards places where the housing stock
simply isn't correct as they grow older
and this is going to be a very serious
problem for us I think
within that of course all these
decisions are are tricky and they cost
money or political Capital uh or both
but actually by making a proper build
you know the built-in and building for
health
in the long run is a huge investment uh
in the population as a whole and in in
general provided it's made clear why
it's good for health and the line of
sight too and my family's health would
be better my view is actually people do
care about this
when it's framed in ways that people
find feel that their choices are being
taken away from them that gets a lot
more tricky so I think just to take the
15 minutes it is uh issue which has
become incredibly politically
complicated for reasons that are uh are
multifactorial let's leave it at that
point
the first principle that everyone should
be able to if possible if they wish to
walk to the shops walk to Public
Services uh use Open Spaces near where
they are not have to travel long
distance for them kind of who's going to
argue with that it's some of the way
that you actually it's then presented
which tends to lead to then the
political concerns that some people have
some of which are easier to you I think
fully understand than others that way
but but the general principle that most
people would want to live in a livable
city that is attractive for them that
allow their children to play play that
allow their elderly relatives to walk to
the shops without having to always get
public transport I don't think there's
huge amounts of opposition to that but
there's a cost to it and that's the
trouble is there's a cost and
particularly there's a cost
um but particularly My worry is that
sometimes the cost of one particular
segment of society is allowed to get
disproportionate weight
so let me just take one example the
thing which worries me in London for
active transport as it does in most
other cities is not when there's a
conflict between cars and cycles that
needs to be managed both need to be
dealt with when they're driving but when
there's a conflict between having a
cycle
walking and driving and large numbers of
parked Vehicles taking huge amounts of
the road space
because they happen to provide
funds for the local Authority
or an individual who's got a parking
space and they're not going to give it
up without a right
now that car is used hardly at all in
reality and yet that's the thing which
is causing the conflict between the
active transport and the car
now that can require political bravery
to come overcome that but actually once
achieved the outcomes are very positive
for everybody because the health goes up
the active transport goes up and the
people being able to drive as they wish
goes up so a lot of these things it's
about saying where is there an interest
which ultimately is not is is
disproportionate and that is
fundamentally an issue of politics
that's not a people like me can say in
principle you have to actually do what
you can to improve it but that's a
political choice and that has to be
argued in the public domain at that
point I think lends itself to the next
concern I have so the government quite
rightfully wants more people to walk and
cycle to get around and National
government's given uh the murder in
Greater Manchester um great Manchester
mp uh money for the B Network
and there are projects which are being
designed so you have a better structure
for cycling
um and I just wonder sometimes whether
the focus would be better on sorting out
the potholes and that basic maintenance
which is often neglected so people can
see constituents can see that there's a
substantial amount of money for
redesigning and existing quite
reasonably good road when potholes
aren't being filled in I know this more
of a transport question but if it's
driven from the center saying you've got
to really push this active travel agenda
but actually ignores the basics which
enable people to cycle because deterrent
to cycling would be uh pothole written
roads I'll give a general thing and then
you might want to talk about Manchester
you know very well
um
the the issue for you know let's take
the cycling and other forms of outer
transport what I really care about as a
public health person is not that a
middle-aged man who loves cycling goes
110 miles rather than 100 miles I care
that a slightly uh beginning to be at
slightly living with a bit more weight
than they'd want uh sort of older
diabetic woman has the opportunity
safely to get from point A to point B by
active transport with a whichever form
they choose
on the routes that they want to go on
that to me is a huge Public Health win
and I think we often forget that quite
short distances of people who are
children people who are older are in
public health terms probably more
important than having a long cycle route
out in the countryside which is great
for people who are doing it and all for
it to be clear and not saying there's a
bad things
those are really important now if what's
stopping them is a pothole then that's
important because safety is really key
critical to this and this is my final
point on this point which is what's the
disincentive to cycling
apart from people not being able to so
teaching it at school is a really
critical thing feeling safe on the road
is really important and knowing that you
can leave your your cycle at either end
and it's not going to disappear is also
important quite reasonably if you can
fix those a lot of people will use
active transport and if you look back to
the 50s the huge demographic of the UK
older younger Every Generation all
cycled or walked it's a big shift away
from that two cars which in public
health terms is bad in multiple ways
from waging range from air pollution to
lack of exercise so you know actually
thinking how were these cities until 40
years ago and how can we recreate that
seems to me a legitimate thing to
actually ask the question and that's not
mainly about potholes no I've got very
little time I've got my in Greater
Manchester greatest Manchester facial
framework which is to set out the house
building and other things as well other
infrastructure to go along with it and
you look at it and it could be broadly
described as a donut around the city of
Manchester for executive homes and these
sorts of housing Estates on developments
don't lend themselves to public
transport and they don't lend themselves
to active travel they might in the local
area but they certainly don't when you
want to go to work you've got to get in
your car and there's aspects of as well
primary schools for example the number
of when there's a new Primary School
development is very rarely a new single
form entry primary school with a
relatively close catchment area is often
to and had a proposal recently in the
constituency for free form entry Primary
School aren't you demanding if you do
that coming from
government
or the local Authority the trust in the
department for Education if you have
these sorts of developments you're
requiring people to drive you're a
Manchester person
briefly please very briefly I was first
I've taken away from Manchester which uh
yes I do I was a director of Public
Health in Manchester I still live in
Manchester
um but um I think what we're doing with
with oh here I mean these are very
complex areas I know the special
framework and all the political uh
conundrums that were part of getting
that through but um I think what we're
trying to do with ohid is look at the
evidence look at the evidence base
um work in terms of how you can have
what's the evidence base in terms of
health and health promotion of something
like adaptive transport or housing and
then work with the chief planner and
deal like in terms of looking at the
national planning policy framework and
maybe change changes that could happen
there how can we help and support local
areas to have the best way that they can
understand what those choices are
between
um you know the balance the tensions
that are there but what's the evidence
base about what choices that they can
make and I think that the point in terms
of the future future threats Chris's
point about well who would have thought
the car might have you know
contributed in terms of air pollution or
increased physical activity it's trying
to think ahead to what are those kinds
of towns or places that we want to live
in and and do our something like our
planning Frameworks really enable local
communities to create the best places
for for people who live in those both
either through children's through the
life course and until being older people
so that people can stay within the
communities should they wish to I
appreciate the points you've made my
concern is I I think what you're saying
is right but I think the practices are
quite removed from it thank you
amazing uh okay poor Bristol uh thank
you chair
um
the NHS historically has been geared
towards episodic care treatment tariff
is obviously example
and in local government political
priorities are often well public health
is not often a political priority
certainly the immediate term because
they've got local elections and things
like that to concede with do you think
that we have the right system in place
and the right levers and drivers in
order to ensure that appropriate
investment is made into public health
um my view is that
the system is it you can change systems
infinitely uh my view is that the
current ICS ICB model is probably a
reasonable one because it brings
together local authorities in the NHS in
one place and they have not always seen
eye to eye I think that's a safe thing
to say I'm sure if you've seen this as
constituency MPS because they do they
both own very major parts of the
solutions on particularly on prevention
as does central government so that's
essentially the triumvirate of groups
that can do something about it but I
think what we've really got to do is
make it work and my worry here if I'm
honest is that the bits which were not
working as well prior to this change
could end up with not working very well
ICS ITB and the ones that were working
incredibly well previously will end up
with a very good system and and since we
won't shift the dial in the areas where
there's less good provision so I think
what we've really got to do is look at
the areas which have historically not
done so well at bringing together well
I'm not gonna I'm not going to name
names on this one but I think if you
look at the map of the country you can
see where the life expectancy is lowest
that doesn't mean that they've
necessarily failed but those are the
ones where we really need to put our
effort into they've often been extremely
good actually but they need the extra
effort and they are really clear to see
you can look at the ons data on this
it's you can get it down to Ward level
and you can see which of the areas which
really need the help and that is not a
matter of time change in the system it's
about saying we've got to make it be
serious about X area I guess my my
questions around
um incentive and yes absolutely you can
look at a map look at a city like mine
in Peterborough and you call it certain
Wards in Peterborough like Rachel was
saying earlier you know there was huge
um discrepancies in life expectancy
across my city you know there's some
wards that do exceptionally well on
others who don't it was the same during
covert
um but I guess my question is within the
existing systems we have is are we going
to have an incentive situation where the
incentive is towards those longer term
investment in public health and
prevention against as you were saying
earlier
um ambulance times waiting lists the
things that kind of keep I suppose
Hospital CEOs awoke at night
I I think that the key is not the
structure and that's my main point I
think yeah I was in Peterborough very
recently I've seen exactly what you're
talking about in terms of the
extraordinary gradient and also within
the most difficult areas from a health
point of view extraordinary local
leadership from local politicians from
GPS from others who are determined to
turn things around but it is almost
always an issue about leaders and I
don't mean that in terms of necessarily
a political leader although at the end
it has to be judged by political leaders
saying actually for my area these are
where the priorities are I'm going to
live here for my whole life I want it in
when I when I retire when I leave office
whenever it is I want it to be better
for my family and my neighbors than I
found it and the lead the local
leadership you see is very very
heartening
what unfortunately is less heartening as
you go to areas which have got serious
problems and Leadership isn't there and
it's random across the system
unfortunately and getting good leaders
into the areas where we've got the
biggest problems seems to me the biggest
priority because they will take the
risks and about holding the risk and
saying yes it'll be unpopular for a year
or two but actually viewed over a decade
this can be transformational and I'm
going to hold my nerve I'm going to keep
going because the evidence is very
clearly that if we do this this is going
to improve health locally and indeed the
local environment okay well I think the
center you visited in Peterborough is a
favorite of mine and my local GP Service
as well and they do exceptional work do
we spend enough money on public health
well I would my view is that we should
spend more of the money we spend on
health towards prevention which I think
is the point of this whole inquiry uh
how much money we put into health is
ultimately a political decision which is
why I tend to steer clear of it as a
health person obviously I'm going to be
in favor of that but but that but the
question within the fixed Health budget
should more of it go into primary
prevention and secondary prevention my
view is yes
but on primary prevention a lot of the
capital to be used up is in fact
political Capital not money capital and
that's a decision for people around this
table not for me do you think it would
be wise to divert money from secondary
care hospitals to
prevention I would like people in
secondary care to do prevention in fact
that was the the chair mentioned an
article I wrote in the bmj earlier this
year part of my point was don't just
leave this to GPS this should be
everybody's problem it should be nurses
problems it should be Consultants you
know I speak as a secondary consultant
myself we should be thinking when
someone comes in not just about the
immediate problem but also about their
blood pressure about their risk for
cancer and all of these areas so it's
really Shifting the emphasis of the
health service from a small number of
people do the prevention which is people
with public health or Primary Care in
their title to this is a whole of system
problem which everybody should actually
contribute to and make every you know
make make it much more of a sense of
this is what the whole system is there
to do you can fully appreciate the
sensitivities in diverting money away
from hospitals let's say to deal with a
an immediate problem in hospital into
public health or prevention
well that but I didn't say that what I
said was uh within the Health Service if
you want to be in a situation where you
say press and repeat and all the
problems we have every winter are the
same problem but they're getting worse
because the population is getting older
then the way to do that is not to take
Public Health seriously and not take
prevention seriously so if you took a
hundred doctors and 100 nurses and ask
them the same question should more of
Health money go into prevention I'm
confident the overwhelming majority
would say yes this is not a I happen to
be a public health person I'm also a job
being NHS consultant
I and my colleagues would all agree if
well targeted if well evidenced so not
doing fatty things if well targeted I
think everyone would agree this is the
way you stop the hamster wheel going
around at an increasingly fast rate
personally I agree with you but I think
it's a very
it's a very difficult thing to achieve I
think but we need to do that is why I'm
we are so fortunate to have bold
political leaders who can take these
long-term decisions
yeah
I see why you've lasted so long
[Laughter]
um could I just end by asking you about
very Upstream prevention which is one of
the things that we we want to look at in
this work so genomics PLC uh sent us a
good submission about screening um
suggesting that should be much more
targeted using genomic data to identify
those most at risk we had a range of
submissions calling for genomic testing
on conditions such as
hemochromatosis I think I've got that
right aortic dissection it's been
championed by my colleague from mid
Derbyshire who certainly lost her son to
A.D and has really LED on this form the
new charity cancer spinal muscular
atrophy you'll be aware of the NHS
Gallery trial that's being done with the
the organization Grail led by Harper
Kumar I used to run CI UK of course
um that is a fascinating study in can
detect very early stage cancers from a a
blood draw a single blood draw
is that the future of prevention
Upstream early detection of cancers
which pancreatic cancer which you know
obviously is very hard to detect in
early stages and bowel is that the
future of prevention when it comes to
some of these conditions so the short
answer is yes it's not in every area so
you know
do I want to detect lung cancer earlier
absolutely because the outcomes get
better but not good do I want to prevent
Lung Cancer by stopping through the
smoking that's clearly far better on
lung cancer but let's take the example
you took of pancreatic cancer there are
things you can do to help reduce the
risk of it but still a lot of people
will get pancreatic cancer the earlier
you can pick up things like that or
esophageal cancer or to take a one where
it makes a huge difference ovarian
cancer which is usually picked up far
too late
and in the major cancers that people
will come across friends and family in
almost every family for example breast
cancer prostate cancer bowel cancer the
really large ones that across all of the
population the earlier you pick them up
the smaller the procedure you have to
deal with the less it impacts on
people's lives uh the less it has
long-term effects there are so many
advantages to going Upstream but
there is a danger that if you go
Upstream with something that isn't very
very specific just to take the Grail
example and that's still in Exploration
we don't know some of it will work some
of it won't
let's take prostate cancer a very large
number of people with prostate cancer
will die either never knowing they've
had it or it certainly contributes in no
way to their poor quality of life or
their death in the end of it
what you don't want is large numbers of
people to diagnose the things which they
actually early treatment isn't going to
help them at all in fact they get the
disbenefits the treatment but not the
benefits so for example screening for
prostate cancer
uh gives you large numbers of men who
have the side effects of over treatment
and doesn't improve your quality of life
your your quality of outcomes at all at
this point now the way we deal with that
is to get better testing better
targeting and this is what the genetic
systems are going to allow us it's going
to actually say
you as an individual are much greater
than average risk of diseases one two
and three and much lower risk of
diseases four five and six
and therefore we're going to put the
screening systems on to you much more
frequently for the ones you're more
likely to have actually will do less of
the screening for the ones you're less
likely to have because we've wrist
ratified you in a much more
sophisticated way and that is going to
be possible from here on genetics has
been one ohm genomics being one element
of that but not by any means the only
one there are many other ways you can
stratify by risk where we actually
stratify people's risk and actually
intensively follow people for the
diseases they're likely to get given
their genetic or social environment and
much less for the things they're much
less like to get we already do it a bit
by age and gender would it follow then
that we would draw back from more
population level screening for breast or
the fit test for poo in the post
um would we draw back from that to then
increase the more personalized screening
because because you know come back to
where we started to complete the loop if
we just keep adding more things that the
NHS is going to do then we either just
keep increasing the budget and spend
more and more on health and health
spending Rises faster than GDP not a
very sustainable place
um
given the workforce chances we have
or are you saying that this would come
on top of everything else that the NHS
is currently doing through its screening
programs for instance well firstly if
you pick something up early you're
almost certainly going to lead to less
work for NHS because it's much easier to
treat earlier but that's a that's not
the point the main point you're making
I'm just adding that let's take the fit
test
if we know that someone has a genetic
condition called Lynch syndrome for
example you'd want to do it more
frequently and earlier that there'd be
other people at the other end of the
spectrum where you think actually we
donated it very often at all so we may
well be able to balance it
putting it away from the people who
really need much less of it and much
more towards people who need more of it
so let's say breast cancer if someone
has bracha 1 or bracket 2 mutations
you'd want them to be screened earlier
and more frequently there are other
people with no family history and no
genetic risks so you might well see
really quite infrequent screening is
necessary and of course there are some
things whereby prevention we actually
can wind back from it almost entirely so
I anticipate a period where we will in
the future be able to have minimal or no
cervical screening because the
vaccination will simply have got rid of
yes the risk so I would you know the
thing I would like most is a thing which
takes the risk away completely and then
next down what I'd like to do is Target
the what we do more towards those at
greater risk and actually do less for
those who are actually at lower risk
because it just doesn't make sense and
actually risk benefit in fact does not
help them particularly and it just eases
up resources for no clinical benefit
I think it's a brilliant place to end
and uh it's been a brilliant session to
start this prevention inquiry so thank
you so much for your your time I hope
you follow our deliberations and we will
obviously stay in touch with you so um
Dr Jeanette degushi and Jonathan Maron
and Professor Chris Whitty thanks very
much for giving evidence that concludes
the session order
the proceeding has ended